good morning
millennials welcome back to the morning
toast happy
hump day
[Laughter]
happy hump day what a beautiful
beautiful hump day
kind of like it's gross outside on a
hump day i would rather it be raining so
that i'm staying in and i'm pumping
someone i love and not like
feeling like i should be outside no i
think in this whole like work from home
age like the rain really isn't that
annoying if anything it's like less of
an excuse to be productive so
it gets like dark it's like moody you
know i kind of feel that like a little
bit
yeah like today it's like not that
disruptive so
i'm kind of here for the vibes of course
the show like gets a little darker
outside but i think it looks like
it sets a nice tone it does it gives
like a very forks
ear up forksy yeah forksy vibe so we
look like ghostly
but maybe i'll suck your blood later i
mean i don't know if i look ghosty i
think i look super cool today
i think i do too vitamin sweater joggers
yeezys yes
are those uh spring summer spring summer
joggers
she wear shirt she buys tray i'm wearing
she buys right today september that's
spring summer i'm not wearing shiba
shrey by the way but i would be if
if if they sold it anywhere um i'm
wearing chanel
top bottom everything head to toe chanel
yeah everything's
expensive everything rich no but this is
one of like the most premium
brands out there morning toast merch it
literally does not get better than
shopwarningchest.com i'm wearing
the hammerton teal jumpsuit and it's
literally
every day i get home from the toast and
like i work from the couch i put this on
every day like this is so dirty because
i've been wearing it
for a week straight but i just love it i
love it it looks so cute on you and your
sneakers are super fancy i feel like you
don't really give them credit because
like you wear them a lot this is just my
first time wearing my yeezys so i'm not
going to stop talking about them
yeah but you're always wearing fancy
sneakers including today well so if you
read my book which i know you did like
four times i have this
really big philosophy about like not
spending like money on designer clothes
because like my weight fluctuates so
much but jewelry shoes and handbags are
really you know timeless when you're a
big fat girl like me so
i yes i pretty much every day wear louis
vuitton sneakers because i can't
so fancy and because you really except
maybe if you're pregnant you really
can't grow out of sneakers
like these are worn down i wear them
every single day yeah your sneakers are
actually fancier than mine
i don't like to brag well i just feel
like
i'm wearing yeezys and everyone should
know no like let's talk more about it
where did you procure them really good
no i got into
a um an investment war on stockx
and they just other people were
outbidding me and i was like you know
what i have to part like with
this shoe i got these on the real reel
where you where you
get it for the price that it's listed at
and you don't have to like start
competing yeah um speaking of
investments
i don't know if you know but when i
checked this morning you know dogecoin i
have to keep you abreast because so many
people are buying dogecoin because i'm
talking about it now i feel bad like if
it goes down
so i bought it at 0.04 four cents
as of this morning
it is at .65 that's the highest it's
been at
wow and elon musk is going on snl
and that could affect the price of
dogecoin so even though it's at a high
right now like if you want to get in i
would say before
so should i buy more how much have no i
only spent two hundred dollars and
here's you know what you'll jinx it you
will ruin dojo for everyone if you buy
more i turned
my 200 into 2585. let's go shopping
but should i like imagine if i put in
400. okay and imagine one of his friends
put in 180 thousand dollars and he made
two million dollars imagine
imagine if you put in 100. like you did
what you did you
you played with you played with what you
had i blamed robin hood
i was going to buy like 500 but i didn't
have any money left in my account
so then i i transferred more but it
takes a few days like what give me the
instant transfer right i think stick to
your guns if you make any changes you'll
ruin it for everyone
that's fair but i kind of want to ruin
it forever no kidding
stop no like be happy with what you have
always know like yes of course it could
be better but you also could have put in
less and it could be less so i know
i just like him hearing and i'm so proud
of the fact that why don't you start
talking people who invested less
and then you can stop comparing yourself
to because probably invested a hundred
and eighty thousand dollars like i'm so
competitive so i'm like yeah
so reckless i'm like i got it at .04 and
like that's really good
for 200. look and they're like oh my god
how much
and i've been lying i'm saying 500. okay
but even though they're like that's it
i'm like yeah no i was like
just being conservative yeah you're a
conservative investor
it is what it is it's fine like because
at the end of the day if it all goes to
[ __ ] like i only lost 200
that's what i'm saying and now you get
to like be involved in this cultural
moment
at a bargain price that's fair okay
i guess be happy with what you have
speaking of what you don't have today
where's your coffee oh it's in theo oh
it's already disgusting and i'm so busy
today like i'm probably going to have to
order like a
i've been trying wanting to try duncan
so i might order like you know a donut
for lunch and then get a coffee like the
charlie cold foam or something oh nice
um because i'm just so busy today
we have such a big show we have a guest
we have your toasters i have to run home
after this i'm filming a patreon vlog
with my closet organizers done and done
home i love them they're like the best
mother daughter duo
and like all morning i was just getting
ready for them because like of course
like it has to be messy but i don't want
them to think i'm disgusting like of
course and also you're going to show us
the before so you don't want us to think
you're disgusting i filmed the before
this morning and like i woke up and i
had asked ben all week i said
can you come home wednesday in the
middle of the day for an hour because
we're reorganizing but we also need to
go through and donate stuff and he said
of course of course of course of course
last night he says he can't come
so that's fine but like you have to
clean out your closet right now and he
didn't do it
so i woke up this morning and he was
cleaning out his closet it was actually
like really sweet
like and he did it like he got through
like four or five um
bags of donations so we are like cooking
like today
is a day i've been dreading because it's
so busy but
after today i'm gonna feel amazing it
sounds like you had a busy morning
sounds like one in which you needed a
coffee for it
by the way literally i sat down today
and i'm like honestly i don't think i
have it in me to do the show
i think i'm addicted to coffee and i
don't think that's going to work for me
i don't want to be that girl i could
always bring you one of mine you would
literally
vomit my mommy do you want to try it
sure is it hot
uh it's it's lukewarm now no why that's
weird
hot coffee yeah no never heard of it
no like i'm not drinking that but just
try it because you're doing this
experiment i'll tell you what it is it's
nespresso pod i use the flavor odacio
with almond milk
and the stevia in the raw it it so
smells like coffee such as strong like i
don't even like it that much but it does
the trick
i'm only doing i just wanna if you take
one sip of that you'll be ready to do
the show
i just want to say like i've literally
no interest in drinking this and i'm
doing it purely for the entertainment
value of the show so everyone
please like and subscribe to our channel
please be entertained by this
you guys oh my god it's so strong it's
not hot right
no no it won't burn you or anything it's
it's loose
i'm living doing anything not to take a
sip like
ew ew wait
that doesn't even taste like coffee it
tastes like duty
what is that an espresso with almond
milk
and the seeds i will never get that
taste out of my mouth because it's not
even coffee
it's literal dirt it's a literal coffee
it's dirt that's coffee
dirty jeans
[Music]
well that was you know what that was
entertaining thank you for that so
that's why i do what i do i'm an
entertainer
um when you order from duncan today i
think you should order a few drinks just
to like knock a bunch
out and might i you know what i know
what that you will like that i sometimes
order when i'm hungover because it's
such a sweet treat
a blue culata no a duncancino which is
half coffee
half hot chocolate i mean like i'll try
anything but
i don't really want anything hot right
you did say that
like hot drinks give me like weirdness
and i'll like only drink them when i'm
sick
okay okay but we'll see i'll try
anything take some suggestions people
have been giving you really good
suggestions i mean duncan donuts has
been like thirsting the [ __ ] out on my
tick tock comments like
every video like try the charlie cold
foam it's like pay me to
try the charlie cold foam yeah you
should try cause like she's a teenager
and so are you and i want to drink like
a teen
yeah no and you have the palette of a
teen by the way we have literally an
amazing show like we have
fast five obviously because that's what
we do we also have the real housewives
of new york season premiere
recap and the real housewives of dallas
reunion part one recap
and then we have dear toasters which is
really a highlight of everyone's day
and then we sat down for an interview
with an iconic
actress and toaster madison brown
kirby from dynasty yesterday she came
and chatted with us she brought her dog
it was super fun
so if you're listening as a podcast
it'll be at the end of this episode and
if you're on youtube
the video will be up probably right now
so fun to speak with a fellow toaster
and fellow star
um fellow star and also just to get all
the tian dynasty um
my super fan like started to become
exposed throughout the interview became
clear like i don't just casually watch
dynasty like i'm literally obsessed with
it yeah it was kind of embarrassing
okay no i think it was flattering no i
don't know i really was um
no like you guys if you have not watched
dynasty we encouraged you like years ago
to watch but if for some reason like you
couldn't get to it you were busy you had
a lot of homework like
watch dynasty treat yourself it's one of
the best shows that's out right now it
really is
and then watch our interview with
madison brown and then speaking of shows
i started the bold type last night
speaking of shows i watched the long
shot big shot oh what did you think
okay it's literal trash yes none of
these people are remotely qualified for
this job i agree like maybe one of them
are qualified to be her intern
yes and i would say so far my front
runner is i i forget her name but the
woman who had
like worked at a magazine before who was
just like very calm and collected
or the younger one not the younger one
oh i like the younger one i like her too
but she's just not
maloxy is her name meloxie used to work
at a magazine she ran her shoot to a t
she has just like good calm energy and i
think bethany needs that
in her group of people i agree she does
have good kind of energy and it really
feels like that he knows that like the
the winner is not in this group i think
she's not going to pick anyone so they
can do another season
i think and i actually know so if you
want another spoiler
no okay i don't want to know no but it's
not really a spoiler they bring in more
contestants
oh great because like people are none of
these people she would need maybe all of
them together
to make up the job like corey is really
sweet but he's just not
like quick enough for her and jenna is
also like precious gem of a woman but
like not it
the one who's like this yeah i didn't
think her name was ally no i think it's
jenna
i think you're right yeah i agree like
really sweet the spirit of skinny girl
but like none of these people
are a chief brand officer right um also
and you know i love bethany and
i didn't agree completely with like what
you had said yesterday about like how
she
she does come off like extra bethany
like on steroids
but like i feel like at the photo shoot
and i'm not like
a fan of nicole's or anything and i and
i think that
for a lot of reasons like it's her time
to go but i felt like bethany was acting
like really immature like laughing
giggling with her friends like
while like making fun of the contestants
like literally in front of them
and also like expecting them to read her
mind on the one hand she says i'm just a
model i'm just a model but then also
treat me like the boss yeah like
it was just like really all over like
you have to be a mind reader in order to
know what she wanted next
fair like i felt like on the one hand
she was like i'm just here i'm not gonna
tell you what to do and then the other
hand like why aren't you doing what i
want you to do
that's are you just a model if that's
the case put on your clothes and wait
your turn
yeah no they weren't given any real
clear direction as to like what
bethany's role was in the photo shoot
and what their role was in the photo
shoot because they were the director but
there was also like a full-blown
director
yeah no i i feel like some people like
managed to do a decent enough job to not
annoy bethany but like
why couldn't bethany put on the dress
herself and then come out
like and say she's ready right like a
model wouldn't go and like sit on a
couch like waiting to be called on like
you you're just like a little more
proactive so like are you the boss or
are you a model like
it required a lot of mind reading when
she was like giggling with luke who by
the way like we know from ladies of
london 100
dan barry's makeup artist and then he
was like dorinda's and then i guess
bethany snatched him
yeah and also like that's always his
role is like snickering with the ladies
like he's actually funny and interesting
no totally when caroline samurai was
like an appleton and like her and luke
like just could not be bothered like
that's what i was watching last night
yeah but like
she was meant to be the boss yes so it
was just
really all over the place required the
candidates to be mind readers and they
can barely even do like
a social media post a social media post
let alone read a mind did you die
no i died also like why didn't why did
everyone think that they were the star
like why not turn the camera around
why not make like a little like
aesthetically pleasing like
like montage you know of how like you
know a real everyone was suddenly an
influencer
like i care about your endorsement i
don't know you
totally like i love i don't care what
you love but did you enjoy the show
no really i did i mean i want i finished
it
but it's it's too stupid because they're
so unqualified yes you know like get
some mbas in the room
of course like just because you're an
event like you need to be in memplanner
a social media manager a pr person
you need an accountant all of those
things not just one from each category
otherwise she should hire everyone but
these people
don't even seem to be the best in their
category 100 i couldn't have said it
better myself
the bold type which i honestly i was
skeptical about like it was giving me
like
before i knew anything about it like i
did judge a book by its cover it was
giving me just like lame ass
free form vibes 100 um but here's what
really shocked me one that the episodes
were 60 minutes i just i don't know why
i expected them to be 30 which
makes the show like so fake yeah um the
soundtrack to the show like really puts
you in your feels like they
nail the song of the moment and it's
always a song you know and i'm just like
they played an indie grammar song i'm
like this is everything right or it's a
song that you don't know but now you're
glad that you do
yes and at first i was like really
unsure about the characters because like
jane is
so [ __ ] lame and i didn't really
understand sutton and i liked cat off
the bat
but then as things started to change i'm
like wow i really hate jane
i like die for sutton and i still like
relate to cat
so i'm just i'm just having this journey
this kind of renaissance with the show
and i'm really really enjoying it
and i just love like this fake world
that they live in where like you know
they're all 25 and like would actually
like be talking to the editor-in-chief
of their magazine let alone be mentored
by them
jan that's her name on the office i
don't know what her realm jacqueline
on the show no like what's her name in
real life i don't know she is such a
good actress i literally die for her
and she's just like this really kind of
maternal no editor-in-chief is like that
but i'm playing into the fantasy of the
bold type and i'm just loving how she's
there for the girl she's just like
a mentor she bails cat out of jail like
no questions asked yeah
like i'm just like i'm really living for
the character development from everyone
except for jane
yeah you know what but like just keep
watching because i do feel like
at some points like you feel vindicated
and like the characters like they learn
the hard way
good that's what i love and that's why
like i really loved so many of daryn
stark's productions because he makes his
protagonist liza and carrie bradshaw
so unlikable but then like the most
embarrassing things happen to them and
it makes you feel
so good inside harry falls on her face
and you're in paris and everything
the whole season the whole series is set
right 100
like 100 he knows how to humble his most
annoying protagonists and for that like
we have to stand darren stark 100
i'm so glad that you liked it so glad
you took the suggestion you know i'm
you got it right to work you were right
i love to hear it and i took your
suggestion
and i was wrong no it was exactly what
you said it was
yes and like it was just funny to watch
i watched
like wound up watching so much tv last
night because then real housewives so
i think without further ado we need to
get into the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
because we've got much to discuss and
today's episode is brought to you by
legacy box a super simple mail and
service to have all your video tapes
camcorder tapes film wheels
and pictures digitally preserved on a
thumb drive a dvd or the cloud
and with mother's day's fa mother's day
fast approaching if you don't know what
to get your mom
why don't you get why don't you get her
the gift of memories do you guys have
boxes and bins of like vcrs old tapes
that you don't know actually how to
watch and access but you just
hold on to them for the memories legacy
box is a fabulous service where they
literally do
all the digital preservation for you
they help bring life to your old media
by unlocking those trapped family
memories
and putting them on a model modern
digital format that's easy to use
the process is super easy you pack and
send the stuff their team will digitize
everything by hand and then you enjoy
you get back perfectly preserved digital
copies on a thumb drive dvd or the cloud
and it's ready to watch share and enjoy
plus they'll keep you up to date with
regular email updates throughout the
process
they're the world's largest digitizer of
home movies and photos and they've
helped over a million
families preserve their past digitally
rediscover your glory days by digitizing
these irreplaceable heirlooms with
legacy box
honestly if you've ever tried to like
get your vcr to work and you like buy
this weird thing online
it's so stressful and it's actually so
fun to go back and watch those videos
and it's a great gift for someone like a
mom or a grandma in your life for
mother's day
and they're having a 50 off mother's day
special so you order your legacy box
today to take advantage of this
incredible offer
it's one of the best discounts they've
offered yet legacy box is perfect for
you or someone you love
at legacybox.com toast to save 50
while supplies last that's legacybox.com
toast love it okay you ready
ready come and find me
i'm okay first story tic toc user claims
ben
affleck sent her a video after matching
on raya
i saw it single ben affleck is allegedly
swiping white right on dating apps when
he's not meeting up with his ex-fiance
j-lo
a tick-tock user named nevine jay went
viral on monday after sharing a private
video the actor allegedly sent her to
confirm his identity on the raya dating
app
she said thinking of the time i matched
with ben affleck on raya and thought it
was fake so i unmatched him and he sent
me a video on instagram
then she plays the video where he said
vine why did you unmatch me
it's me so i had a few thoughts when i
saw the video
the first was wow ben affleck is
actually a lot more handsome
than i like think of him as i don't
really think of him as cute like i know
he was cute when he was younger
but he's just like so messy these days
and like i don't know i just haven't
been able to like look at him the same
way since he like ran out of town with a
nanny you know
um but i was like wow he looks like tan
and toned and young and fit and i was
like damn he's super cute
and then i'm like wow this really cute
man is an absolute freak because the way
he's talking to the camera is
serial killer
naveen why'd you unmatch me it's me
like he's being so weird
and i'm like oh my god i'm so glad she
unmatched him like he is a serial killer
like
just the way he was like staring into
the camera and the way he was talking so
slow
it was such like jeffrey dahmer vibes
like it was so scary oh my god i had the
total opposite
reaction i was just like this is so cute
and like
i feel like when you're on dating apps
you match so many people who would even
notice if someone unmatched you
like he really took the time well that
girl was like stunning he took the time
to follow up with this girl like
she made an impact and he went out of
his way to reach out to her like if i
were her i would not have put that on
tick tock and i would have accepted a
date well of course then it's like
kind of makes me feel bad because even
though i'm like living for it like it is
like an invasion of privacy it's like
i think it's the sort of thing that
makes him look good you think it makes
you look like a serial killer no no no
that's just my person that's me being
judgmental
of course i think it's a nice the story
it's like a personal touch
the story is very nice but like just the
way he was acting i was like
don't ever leave me in a room alone with
this man okay i thought that it just
showed that he cared and that like she
really stood out
obviously he can never go out with her
now because anyone that would post this
like
obviously this has given me a ruthie
like situation it's over before it
started speaking of ruthie jonah hill
just bought a nine million dollar house
ruthie could have been living there it
should have been ruthie's house
should have been lady of the matter i
was looking at pictures of the house and
like ruthie at the dining table ruthie
on the staircase
the grand piano ruthie in the pool
ruthie in the hot tub ruthie would have
loved that pool that rooftop ruthie
would have plopped
roofie
where is ruthie like where is she she
literally disappeared
if you don't know this rudy saga
honestly i can't get into it like just
ask a fellow toaster all you need to
know is justice for ruthie she would
have loved that roofie
by the way i don't even know if there is
a roof but i'm sure there is oh i mean
nine million dollars you don't get a
roof
no actually i'm pretty sure i did see a
roof because it showed that there was a
lot of other houses like nearby and it's
like
if you're jonah hill and you're buying a
house for you and ruthie you obviously
get a roofie
obviously oh my god
that is so funny it's so funny i miss
ruthie and jonah
obviously not we're not laughing at
roofie like the drugs no it's ruthie on
the roof period
roofie um
so yeah ben affleck i say p john you say
p
jeffrey dahmer no he definitely gave
like a half p jump energy a half p
like serial killer energy where it's
like if i met this man and he stabbed me
i would be like i was right
but then if i met this man he was so
sweet i would also be like i was right
you know right he gives me both energy
and i'm just like where is the soft
spoken voice coming from
the jeffrey dahmer side of him or the
pedro side of him
we shall never know we shall never know
no but his like dating life is really
all over the place right now i i'd like
to see him settled soon me too i think
like
honestly i miss him and anna that's what
i was just about to say i think anna
thomas was like the last good thing that
happened to him
yeah i don't think he's getting back
with j.lo no me neither especially after
something like this i feel like even if
they had a chance like jayla's just done
with men
who reach out to women on instagram oh
100
and this is this is she needs to date a
man who does not have instagram this is
a pattern like
literally even though it's sweet like
ben affleck being on raya really
like rya is for fake famous people but
ben affleck is like an actual a-list
megastar yeah why are you on there maybe
it's for real famous people
honestly jayla i need to date like brad
pitt no jlo needs to date
someone who doesn't have instagram does
brad pitt no okay but
i i think she needs an accountant still
yeah me too like a businessman bow
everybody needs one it's the solution to
every problem 100
we're wishing our best to ben affleck
and the vine
you blew it okay are you ready for our
next you will [ __ ] blew it
yes you can join ruthie over with the
people yeah with the sad sacks
who publicized a celebrity relationship
before it even started and unfortunately
it didn't come to fruition this is a
sign that the only thing you should be
publicizing is your nests
100 and the nest happens once the
relationship is fortified 100
only our jewish testers will understand
what the [ __ ] we're talking about are
you ready for our next story
no peloton drama over at peloton they're
recalling
all treadmills after reports of injuries
and one death
so the peloton treadmill wait has been a
source of
drama and injury i have to send this
link to brian
i'm sure he's seen it no no no literally
did he just order a treadmill because
i've literally been
dying for one um bad choice of words but
i really really want one because i when
i go to a gym that's like not
i don't when i'm at a hotel or whatever
i use the gym i use a regular treadmill
and i do a peloton tread class
on a regular treadmill and it's such a
good workout and i just feel convinced
that if i had a peloton treadmill
like my body would change i just sent
that link to brian because brian is in
the hamptons
and he hasn't been at his house in a
while and he's there with his friend
john everyone knows we talked about him
on the podcast and john wanted to try
the peloton
treadmill and literally mysterious
like can't walk like he literally like
they don't know what happened is like
brian has like run out and get him like
an ace bandage and like
all this [ __ ] like literally he did the
peloton treadmill and now he literally
like can't move his leg
whoa and they're like they don't know
what happened i thought the issues with
pelton treadmill were because like
you need to put the safety on and if you
don't the treadmill just starts moving
so like dogs and kids were just like
getting mixed up
in the treadmill yeah so i thought they
were coming out with a new treadmill
called the tread coming out at the end
of this month that's one that i wanted
to get
but called the tread plus but tread plus
is being recalled as well
interesting you know i think treadmills
are like very underratedly dangerous
yeah like one finger in the wrong place
like a kid like i don't know treadmills
that's why i don't have one
treadmills give me spooky vibes yeah
that
i hear you i was literally like about to
use the treadmill today um i probably
still will today yeah at the in my
gym in my building this morning for a
slot yesterday like i was like i want to
use a treadmill because i just need to
switch up my workouts it's like what
i've realized like the bike
it's not enough so i was like i'm gonna
go to the gym my building use the
treadmill i went down there it's like
locked
and then it turns out it's like one
person at a time due to covet you have
to sign up the list is like weeks in
advance
like i just can't can't july first can't
come fast enough
no and like okay where am i gonna be on
july first like who
am i going to want to be in the mood to
to work out like
who knows where i'm going to be yeah
emotionally mentally and physically
yeah so i'm i was so close to writing a
peloton treadmill i'm just so relieved
that i didn't
no are people getting their money back
yes so the company is advising customers
who already
have the products to stop immediately
using it and contact peloton for a full
refund or other
qualified remedy the u.s consumer
product safety commission had previously
warned about peloton's tread plus
product last month
after one child died in an incident
involving the machine
and there were dozens of other reported
injuries that's terrible
heliton pushed back on the recommended
recall at the time and told customers
there was no reason to stop using its
treadmills
but now they're saying we want to be
clear we made a mistake in our initial
response we should have engaged more
productively with them from the outset
for that i apologize
and now the tread and tread plus are
being recalled oh i just got a pit
yeah kid died yeah that's terrible yeah
so if you have a peloton tread
be careful
are you ready for our next story it's
some it's some good i feel like new york
city news some
news i've been waiting for sort of okay
the banks are coming back to work
oh yeah the banks are gonna
save us the banks like the wall street
workers are coming back office culture
is researching goldman sachs top brass
has formulated a plan
to have u.s and uk employees return to
offices next month
as wall street's march back to
skyscrapers gathers pace
u.s staff should be prepared to by june
14th to work from offices again
while those in the uk should be ready by
june 21st the move follows a mandate
last week from jpmorgan chase and co
chief jamie dimon seeking to bring back
his workforce in rotations from early
july
so the reason i want to talk about this
is i feel like new york is coming back
and when it's a beautiful saturday
people are out like yeah
the vibes are good but i think a really
big piece to new york coming back
is people getting back to work in the
office i agree and i think wall street
is the first it's the biggest industry
in the city so like
it once they start i think others will
follow and i think that that is like a
really important
step to getting normal happy hours and
just like working
and like corporate like lunch culture
restaurants even like
places that are there are so many
restaurants that we're only open monday
through friday
right to serve like these huge office
buildings because they like make a salad
in five seconds
yes exactly and so i feel like for
businesses for just like
community and culture like people
getting back into the office
is a really important next step yeah i
mean honestly though
like i see it from both sides because
obviously as a new yorker
i agree like people office culture going
back to offices is like a huge step in
the right direction but like
i can just be imagine being a person who
works in an office and like having to go
back like
i imagine that people are dreading it
i think it's i think people feel like
both ways i think on the one hand
they're dreading it they used to they
can just like roll over
pajamas you know with their dogs their
kids like
yes even though it sucks like there have
been benefits yes
i think people are also having cabin
fever and are ready to like have that
delineation in their life again
yes at a cost of waking up earlier and
being more tired and all of those things
but like
it's not all just fun and games working
from home no of course not but there are
benefits especially if you have kids
there are but it's also downside if you
have kids your kids bother the [ __ ] out
of you like yeah and you have to like
start schooling them too
right no it's a banker and a teacher but
i just know if this were me like
i would be like devastated to go back to
the office
i don't know after a year of working
from home i think i may be excited to
get dressed up again you know see people
like hey like water coolers
like drama like i don't know i think
that
people might be excited for that and i'm
personally just excited to like
see like people in the street you know
no me too but i'm honestly like what you
said about they're really like this
funnel for so many other things like so
many restaurants rely on corporate
culture so
i think that'll be really good and it is
just like the
step we have to take to get back to
normal so it's all great and i think
it's it's a big
step and also i think some companies
will have like rotations of like
somewhere from home
so you'll still get like i don't think
it'll go full 9 to 5
24 5. well because that's the other
thing it's like now that we all realize
that we can do
pretty much i really hope this gives
like
more culture and just like people more
flexibility like we lost a year of our
lives like we should all be able to like
travel the next year and like
take trips but also work we can work
from a plane we can work for anywhere
like being in the office
shouldn't be so required because as
we've proven over the last like 18
years we can do anything from home yes
so i just think we should keep that in
mind moving forward
and i think here at the toast we are
keeping that in mind and we know we can
do the show from anywhere now and we're
gonna
we're gonna take advantage of that i
want that for everyone
i want jp morgan to follow that example
i want goldman sachs to follow our
example like i just want everyone to
realize they can do their jobs from
wherever i want scarlet magazine
to follow that example totally don't you
want to work at scarlet magazine like
don't you feel like watching the bull
type like that's the exact sort of thing
that needs to come back in order for new
york to really
like start to be new york again yes
that like even though it's not like that
you know office most
office cultures are like quiet and gray
and boring yeah because of you know hr
yeah but not here at the toast and we
set the tone for a vibrant
work i think we set the tone for our
generation 100 and we definitely are
setting the tone for jp morgan
goldman sachs deutsche like they're all
looking at us being like how can we be
more like the more deutsche for sure
and swiss swiss is like kind of annoying
like how much
how much they're kind of like copying us
i couldn't agree more
um before we move forward i just have a
message from our sponsor if you have an
fsa account
chances are you're not taking full
advantage of it so many people are
unaware of how many everyday purchases
are covered by their accounts everything
from cold and allergy medications
prescription glasses
tampons and pads acne treatments
sunscreen and so much more
trusted by millions of americans
fsastore.com is the largest site
with thousands of exclusively fsa
eligible products guaranteed
whether customers have questions about
their accounts want recommendations on
products or assistance on their orders
fsastore.com trained professionals are
available 24 7.
with 24 7 expert customer support
fsastore.com
is everything flex spending with zero
guesswork no receipts necessary
head to fsastore.com and use the code
toast
to get a one-time discount of 15 off
your order of 150
or more that's fsastore.com code toast
15 off your order of 150 or more
thank you for that also our next story
sort of relates to the previous story
just the flip side of now we can
do anything from home nyc schools are
scrapping snow days in favor of remote
learning
so now oh my god i would be
furious attention school kids of new
york city you can put all the spoons you
want under your pillow wear your pajamas
inside out
flush ice cubes down the toilet but
you're not getting any more snow days
off from school
the city department of education said on
tuesday that it will take a page from
the
pandemic playbook for the 2021-22 school
year and replace severe weather days
off with all remote instruction okay
like i'm never going back to school but
like i'm furious
for the kids snow days are just like
these small
once a year just moments not even not
even maybe
for the kids and now it's turned into a
remote learning data
you knew this was going to happen think
of the parents who have to like stay
with their kids like their office might
be closed they're working from home like
oh my god that is just so not right
because honestly like
there is really nothing comparable to
the joy
you get when you wake up as a kid and
school is closed like
it's just like i'm smiling just thinking
about it it's
so overwhelmingly joyous
and to rob kids of that when kids
growing up in the pandemic have really
been through a lot and they're not going
to grow up to be entirely normal
they deserve the snow days give them the
snow days
i totally agree people are really upset
about this like this is wrong you're
wrong
and new york city schools like again
like they really set the tone
this is so this is de blasio written all
over it it's so sick
whoever passed this legislature hates
children
yeah and happiness yeah and whoever's
like running for mayor
should add this to their platform andrew
yang barbara cavavid bring it
back just a snow day it could it could
be one day
what's one day no and honestly like snow
days a lot of times like happen
near like the holiday season so it's
just like nice to be home with your
people cultivating
like who wants to cultivate a vibe with
remote learning no
honestly if i was in school right now
like i would literally start protesting
kids are going to take to the streets
you know what i support them i'm very
upset for them
yeah no this isn't right not right the
campers are quaking i heard ac was
inconsolable
[Laughter]
inconsolable yeah that's awful that's a
terrible story yep i thought you needed
to know that i did and are you ready for
our fifth and final story which is going
to lead us into our tv recap
big news out of the real housewives of
dallas reunion carrie brittingham
is divorcing her husband eduardo after
12 years of marriage she says we were
not happy
i mean if you watch the show last season
and this season there was definitely
something up they hinted towards it
with the editing by the end of the
season but honestly like i was not even
a big fan of carrie this season i think
she acted like
atrociously but i felt really bad for
her like
when she was like i'm just gonna have to
work in my jewelry line i'm like girl no
one is buying your jewelry like
it just like felt really bad but i think
she was wearing her jewelry in the
reunion and i thought it looked really
nice
she wears her jewelry like every scene
yeah i never really noticed it before
but i thought that her necklace
and bracelet looked nice i just felt
like really sad for her because like all
the other women were like pitying her
and like
really none of these women of all the
franchises like this is one of the
wealthiest like they all
are so good money-wise and like i just
like felt really bad for her because
like her life is obviously going to
change so much her kids are
older i think they're all over 18. she
can't collect
one little one oh well then she can
collect child support which
i just like i felt so sad for her
because like she kind of
predicted this like she's been talking
about her divorce since we met her like
if we get divorced and i don't have the
house nothing's in my name i have
nothing i have a prenup like
literally what she said was gonna happen
is exactly what happened yeah
really um sad it was nice to see all the
women like rallying around her but also
and i mean maybe it does excuse all of
her behavior this season like she was
having
like she was in an unhappy home and when
she was with the women like she just
wanted to let loose and
she led a little too loose but it did
feel like she's
she's absolved of everything that she
did this season because she was going
through
a very rough time yeah i don't think it
excuses her behavior at all but i do
understand it more but you still are
grown up and you have to apologize to
people for hurting their feelings and
breaking their things in their home
yes and also i think i mean i'm assuming
she'll be on next season because now
like things are interesting and
she did contribute to a lot of the drama
yes and i think a lot of people like
have issues with her but she's
without her there's really not that much
drama and so did deandre say she's going
to live in a townhouse behind deandra's
house
behind deandra's cousin's house got it
d'andra's cousin said that
they bought a house behind hers i'm just
like
i'm like i just don't want us to be sad
like it's a pa it's a
like i just feel i felt really sad and
like i don't even really ever
like care that much about carrie she's
just like kind of all over the place
but i did feel really bad for her but i
was not surprised
yeah especially because they didn't film
together this season at all her and her
husband and when they did in the past
last season was her first season
and it was not good oh last season was
our first season yeah
and remember they went to those dinners
and it was just like awful not good oh
my god it was awful no no
we've known this was gonna happen
honestly just didn't think it would be
so fast and that we would get an
announcement on the reunion
yeah but the reunion otherwise was like
really silly honestly
nothing of note went down
except for the the divorce announcement
but i'm really looking forward to like
brandi redmond did not say one word
one word she was introduced and then
that's it yeah and they cut to her a few
times like show her laughing like to
prove that she was still there but like
she was so quiet and i wonder if she
would have been that quiet if she
was in but i think she might have like
chimed in here and there but like
i i'm sure they encourage them like not
if you're a virtual like don't talk over
because even one time it happened and it
was
really confusing so i think because
nothing had to do with her she was just
like i'm gonna sit this out like her
baby's over there she probably was just
like
i'll speak when spoken to yeah i mean
they looked so turned
in their hotel rooms like with their
hair and makeup their awful lighting
like
brandy's lighting is so bad i just
thought why couldn't
have like delivered a ring light to both
of their rooms
yeah i feel like maybe they did and it's
just still like not good
it's really bad but honestly
it's fine because like the the beef
between
uh cameron wescott and tiffany moon is
just like not what i realized like i so
desperately needed
but i just find it weird that like
cameron wescott who i like adore these
days
has really never like gotten
that heavily involved in drama she's
always kind of like the narrator of the
show and she gets some like petty
arguments like
she just woke up and decided like she
wanted to take down the moons
she's taking the moons down and like
it's kind of a weird hill to die on
because like
although there were moments where i
didn't agree with what tiffany did or
like i found her to be definitely
patronizing
um i just don't know if like that's like
a battle worth taking on
like tiffany is for the most part like
very well liked yeah i hear what you're
saying
i feel like um she
i feel like she's like really hurt by
like the things that tiffany said
calling her dumb basically i'd like to
while they were filming i
and i think that like what afterwards
remember there was all that beef on like
twitter when the show pretty weird like
and i think that like she just took that
stuff really personally and she's just
not gonna let it go
she took it very personally um but i
agree it did sort of come out of nowhere
like tiffany could not get away with
anything yeah and like without chiming
in
which was annoying because if you have a
legitimate gripe with someone like wait
till the moment's right and say you're a
gripe but then if you just go after
everything they say like
you just look like you're going after
them for no reason yeah i also just need
to say like cameron wescott's
look from top to bottom was maybe like
top five reunion
looks of all time on housewives for me
tiffany moon also looks
wonderful um i really was into like
deandra's alternative take on the theme
except why is she wearing a capri that's
the only like
if she wore a tuxedo i think that's very
cool the capri maybe they're just riding
up when she's like crossed her legs i
don't know
i didn't notice it's so off-putting i'm
wearing some capris today okay but
you're not at a reunion
or am i um i really also just
i felt like the whole episode was really
about tiffany and carrie
oh and carrie yeah but it was just like
a lot of tiffany like stuff and a lot of
people
like cameron wescott like saying that
she thought
tiffany's tick tock was inappropriate
like cameron chill out
um but i did kind of want them to go in
on like
how we got so much of tiffany's personal
story and it was really kind of messy
like her mom
seems lovely her mom seemed to support
all of her decisions
and of course her parents aren't happy
with her she'd literally been on a
reality show and
chose violence like she literally chose
to throw her mom under the bus like
so hard season one episode one like that
of all the things like that's the one
thing i just can't kind of get past with
tiffany because when it seems like her
mom is a nice lady and like of course
you never know
what goes on behind closed doors like
why sign up for reality show and like
literally make a conscious choice to
make your mom look bad right and like
finally
bring up all this stuff that you have
not spoken about before
i understand why her parents would be
upset about that i thought it was really
interesting that like the hospital and
like this is like
not good but i feel like and so i i wish
that andy just pressed her a little bit
further on like
why did you join the show what are you
hoping to get out of it because
from my pov i feel like tiffany has
started her own business with um
she's doing candles candles that are
like and it's
that are like almost like medical in
terms of relaxing i think they have like
a bit of um
aromatherapy yes exactly so um i think
this is like her new business endeavor
and maybe she wants like a platform for
that so she could maybe stop
working at the hospital i don't know i
would have liked some more clarity on
that because it's like if everybody in
your life hates that you're doing this
why are you doing this yeah that's true
like your family your work yeah that's
fair but i do feel like on a personal
level she's gotten so much out of the
show like the friendships i feel like
she grew so much on the show i agree
honestly a pleasure to watch she didn't
and i don't think that's why she came on
the show i think that was just like a
bonus by-product but she didn't like
give us enough to understand why she's
here i completely agree because she has
such like a wonderful fabulous life
right and she doesn't really need to
work her husband is
a hotelier yeah i believe like their
wealth comes from that not from her
being in anesthesiology i'm sure it's
like both
no i think it's the hotelier like it's
well so i just i would have liked just
to understand her
her decision making yeah yeah because
she's just like a
tough nut to crack yeah which i i kind
of
like you know not everybody needs to
just lay it all out there
but it is the reason we went into this
line of questioning which i
wasn't even really curious about before
house life seems like a fun thing to do
a lot of the women are really respected
in the community so it's not like
a trashy bad group to be a part of
so i just would have liked more clarity
there
yeah i agree um hopefully we'll get into
it in part two but there's only part two
parts
which is like kind of crazy yeah the
treatment of the dallas housewives and
the ring and last night was like
so 10 30. 10 30 after watch what happens
live
and why not just put it on monday let's
talk about watch what happens live when
literally
andy asks ramona in your opinion what do
you think is the worst franchise and
literally not two minutes before their
reunion errors ramona says dallas
yeah while robin's live was so [ __ ]
messy like the remoteness
all the women live in new york are we
not at a place maybe i'm wrong like i'm
not a place where six people can sit in
a studio together no i believe that we
are
so like because they do reunions like
right they do reunions
it was so bad oh my god it was so blurry
luanne could not get a wi-fi connection
to save her [ __ ] life
everyone was talking over each other and
there was like good nuggets there and we
were just missing everything like i'm
glad i didn't watch then
it was i had no choice because i watched
it from nine to ten
and then i had to watch the dallas
reunion but they stuck [ __ ] watch
what happens live in there yeah awful
but let's talk about new york yes um
the the most shocking thing
leah's outfit to the brunch you didn't
like it
wait what are you doing i thought it was
like cute and fun the patterned skirt
with the plastic the plaid skirt with
the the
leather boots and the moon kylie jenner
furry chanel
i just thought i wouldn't wear it
personally but i thought she was i
thought she looked really good i thought
her glam was on point and like she
she has her own sense of style i thought
she looked cute
i thought she looked cute i'm actually
speechless she just like brings her
own sense of self to she looks at the
group
nuts i think she's so pretty and cute
like she's really stunning
stunning i nuts outfit i thought she
looked
cute and the confessional outfit i
wouldn't wear
that for a married of reasons but i
thought it looks cute on her no that
turtleneck was so cute when i saw her in
the previews just sitting at brunch i'm
like oh my god i love that turtleneck on
her like she should have wears like
leather pants like something
when she got up and walked in i was like
but like oh and then the pink bomber
what was going on but that's just like
her when she said yeah i could wear a
black bag but that'd be so obvious like
cool i'm into it i again like i would go
with the obvious black bag i like to
like be super coordinated
but she not everyone's the same no i'm
not i'm not i thought she looked like
really
good honestly i really did that was my i
hear what you're saying i do
but when i saw her i was like oh wow she
got glam i loved how her hair was done
and she's wearing an outfit that's
designer but also true to herself you're
supposed to be the fashionista of the
two of us
i'm saying like i wouldn't wear it like
because i also like don't have her body
and she could really wear anything yes
um nothing really looks bad on her but i
i like that it was
fashion forward and also took a chance i
love that she's converting to judaism
like
i i don't really understand why yet i'm
sure we'll get into it more
but she's asking her spiritual journey
yeah and she likes the challenge
yeah which is really interesting i hope
we get into it more she did upgrade her
apartment
slightly she she heard you she heard me
laugh bravo heard you because
ebony's apartment is so sickeningly
stunning it looks like a hotel yeah
and i was shocked like i haven't seen a
house that nice on bravo i mean on new
york
since i don't know it was just a relief
luanne upgraded
sonia's back in the townhouse they heard
you out the real estate and they said
ladies let's step it up i mean
luanne's is a rental looks like one
i think better than her upper west side
apartments
and sonya's upper west side apartment of
course i'm so happy sonia's out of
columbus circle and back in the
townhouse
the townhouse looks great sonia feels
like ramona and luanne even though i'm
like actually really jazzed about the
two of them being friends
them coming for sonia just like to have
something to talk about like don't do
that i didn't feel like they were coming
for her
where she's going through something she
just doesn't want to talk to you and
everyone's going through something it's
the pandemic when she was talking about
century 21 and how like
literally she worked so hard just to get
like this one thing and then the second
she got it century 21 files for her bank
up she like
i wanted to cry for her like i feel her
and so she was like taking time for
herself during the pandemic putting
herself first
and like these two going on a wellness
retreat these two like social
butterflies just can't understand that
and so they think she's going through
something more and it's like
let's not make no it's like it's just
what you see that she's going through
yeah
yeah and she's up front she's like no
honestly like the rug was pulled out
from underneath me you know what i also
can't stand when like someone's going
through something and then like
the their friend is like mad at them for
not like leaning on them enough and they
give them more to give the person who's
going through something more to work
make it about you
100 that's like the most selfish thing
you can do i agree ramona looks amazing
they all look we all look amazing yes
luanne like grew her hair out like three
inches and it looks
so good she no longer looks like her
ex-fiance shock she looks so good i love
the energy that she's bringing the
openness about the drinking when she had
that conversation with leah and just
like right off the bat was like i'm
having a really hard time it's like
that's not a luanne that we're familiar
with like she will not admit
defeat until the la until she's in the
back of a cop car she literally
said she was an alcoholic just because
she was like under arrest for it and
then the second her like parole was up
and everything she said she wasn't an
alcoholic and she didn't have a drinking
problem
but i honestly have respect for her for
saying like there was a couple nights
when i didn't know how i got home and
like that was unacceptable like at this
age she was being like so
honest and just like open about
everything which is new for luanne so
i was really i really liked that moment
between the two of them
i thought the episode in general was
really good i'm loving ebony
me too like she went me over with
her outfit to brunch her friendship with
leah and her house like oh my god her
house i just have not i feel like i'm
being spoiled you know the only thing i
care about on housewives is like
if people have nice homes and she just
really hit it out of the park no she hit
it out of the park on al
firing in all cylinders which we love to
see i also love that she's short
like all the women are so tall and as
such like short people like
it just i felt like i felt represented
honestly like some of these women who
just like
when when leah and her were in the back
of the car and ebony was like have they
met anyone like me before and liam was
like a black person
no like and and you can definitely see
like
some of these women like don't know how
to like when sonia was like i have
diverse fish
honestly like i died like i look she's
like
and then ebony was like and you have
body positive fish like it was so cringy
and like
i see her trying to make an effort but
like it was literally
it's old world meets new world like two
like it was so cringy i could have
died yeah but i think that the group
together has like a good
rapport it's clear that the women like
like ebony off the bat
and i'm excited for them to get to the
hamptons even though it looks like
things go south so quickly so quickly at
luann's
right and heather thompson is coming
back and no heather thompson is kind of
like the cornerstone of all the drama
this season like her and leah like
literally
i think she's like suing leah for
assault or something like there's crazy
and she like leaves mid-season yeah i
love heather thompson i feel as though
she wasn't given a fair shot
and i just cannot wait for the scene
where ramona i have been like
loving ramona even though i feel like
the world has started to turn on ramona
i used to hate her and like now i kind
of like her
when she's walking up the stairs in her
audrey hepburn black dress and pearl
necklace
what happened to class to elegance
to elegance and class i can't wait like
ramona is actually
turning into someone i love so much when
i could not
stand her no it goes up and down because
she comes in waves she is the ramona
coaster
she is and she's always true to herself
which you've just gotta respect god
and she's in a good season yeah yes a
hundred percent she looks so amazing
i agree with you i'm totally here for
everything she's bringing
and luanne and the friendship and i just
feel like she's
she's in a good place yeah do you think
that that luanne knew that her balcony
looked into tom's
i actually don't i actually don't i
reported on this one tpg was here and
we're like obviously but then actually
seeing it wasn't directly across the
street it's like a few blocks away and
across the avenue
so i actually think there's a strong
chance she didn't know it's not like
it's a direct
across the street view into someone's
window it's like two blocks up
and one block so i believe her i don't
think lulan is hung up on tom
me neither i really really don't like
i've forgotten about him i think she's
forgotten about him i think she's been
if
she were hung up on him she would still
be married to him yeah and she's with
garth she just like couldn't [ __ ]
stand him
yeah no no i mean he's so annoying yeah
um so it was like a good episode kickoff
nothing major happened but apparently it
goes
down in the hamptons next weekend so
can't wait can't wait
um and before we dive into our interview
with madison brown from dynasty we have
a little deer toasters because it's
wednesday and the deer toasters is
brought to you
by booty by bray bands founded by
fitness instructor kelly bray bands
she is changing the athleisure game with
their high quality durable leggings and
inclusive approach
booty by bray band's leggings sculpture
your body highlight your curves and
we'll take workouts to the next level
with the perfect amount of compression
and support
if i may please takes workouts to the
next level also i have never gotten
so many compliments on my athleisure
than when i wear a booty vibrations like
everyone from like fellow fashionistas
to the trainers are like
that's the maximum like so it looks good
and also it works
out so good but after we did our first
read i got some more stuff from booty by
bray bands and like
sickening colors to like this nice like
burnt orange i'm so excited to wear it
such cute sets they make you look like
so [ __ ] snatched and also you can
move and groove in them
so the ones that you're talking about
are the signature croco skin material
the black croco skin leggings are the
perfect black leggings
every woman needs in their life designed
to last a lifetime and you can also
shop black croco skin bike shorts which
are spring summer stable
yes and you can chop now for 15 off
using the code toast
at booty by bray bands dot com that's b
o o t y
b y b r a b a n t s
booty by bray bands dot com code toast
for fifteen percent off
let's do it to your toasters such great
stuff and also i just wanna say their
non croco
um biker shorts were the first biker
shorts that i wore that didn't ride up
the
entire time they were just so good and
didn't ride up and i think that's so
important in a biker short
all right first stop counselors i'm in
desperate need of some advice and i feel
that your wisdom will resonate with many
other toasters
okay moving season is upon us and there
are uncomfortable roommate conversations
on the horizon
i currently live with my best friend of
over
i currently live with my best friend of
almost 10 years let's call her margot
and the other another girl that we have
lived with for the past three years
let's call her nulls
moved into a house with us right after
college when one of our planned
roommates fell through
we were set up through mutual friends
but hit it off right away and the three
of us moved together into a house the
following year
and have now lived here for almost two
years in the past two years
mine and margo's feelings margot has
been best friends with this girl for 10
years
mine and margo's feelings towards
knowles have changed quite a bit we
found her to be extremely negative and
just generally on a different page than
us this is blasphemy
she has a boyfriend she's she's still in
school she doesn't really like to go out
unless it's with her boyfriend etc
margo and i are single as [ __ ] we drink
way too much we smoke weed we work
full-time we have pets the list goes on
and on
we need to get out of living with her
but we've also gotten so comfortable
with the situation even though we're
constantly bitching about it
that it feels really hard to come clean
on our plans we all
get along and prefer to brush things
under the rud rug rather than address
things head on
i don't know how to approach a
conversation that margo and i want to
move but she's not invited
i'd like to think that she sees it
coming but i'm really not sure that she
that's the case
she doesn't have any other girlfriends
it's been three years so we just kind of
feel responsible for her
i do want to remain friends with her and
her boyfriend so we just need to figure
out how to tell her
without hurting her feelings sincerely a
people-pleasing toaster
so she basically needs advice on how to
tell the third roommate that the two of
them just
aren't moving on without her and
bluntness honesty policy
get get with it like yeah i would try
and like find a reason that you could
like
pin it on you know maybe something about
your late nights or
or whatever china well you found a great
place with two rooms
yes something like that try and find an
excuse to soften the blow but yes at the
end of the day you just need to be
honest
and the more uh heads up you give
someone when it comes to women the nicer
it is like if you leave them high and
dry like the second the least is up like
that's rude so yeah so let her know in
advance that you guys have plans to move
on and give her enough time to
to find her own accommodations but yeah
just
rip the band-aid off yeah you don't have
to live with anyone it's not a crime you
just don't want to hurt someone's
feelings so just say it in a nice way
yeah all right next up hi jackie and
claude this is my first time writing in
but i've been a toaster since the
beginning i love you both
very much i have a dilemma that isn't
very urgent but something that needs to
be dealt with nonetheless
i appreciate any advice in advance this
girl feels like a lawyer like barry
so i have been do so i've been doing
long distance with a guy for about a
month now
we met when i was back in my college
town and he's been visiting me
consistently for the last four weeks
since then
he's amazing and a super sweet guy
however he's quite sensitive so this is
where the problem arises and is also
just weird in general
he currently lives at home with his mom
but both times he stayed with
but both times he stayed with him i've
like she stayed with him she's probably
but both times i've stayed with him
i've noticed all his clothes smell like
they've been left in the laundry for too
long
what i realized no oh
i guess if you leave your laundry in the
machine for too long
it could get like moldy if you leave it
in the water the wash
i realize this can be an issue with
washing machine oh look i think she
means like moldy
okay i realize this can be an issue with
the washing machine but honestly it
really starts to bother me when the
smell permeates to my room slash bed
he's so amazing and i really do like him
but i don't know how to address this
like i can't just straight tell him i
feel like that's such an awkward
conversation
any advice is welcome sincerely a
toaster with a smelly man the thing is
you don't have a smelly man you have a
man with smelly clothes which is such a
better predicament to be in than
a smelly man because telling someone
they smell is hurting their feelings
telling them when their clothes smells
is like just a matter of fact okay also
martin teen when i was like doing so
much laundry
and my stuff started my towel started to
have that like moldy smell
and i just like the toasters told me
that like you can over wash towels
and you do like a um you strip it with
borax
yeah what's it called the vinegar the
apple cider vinegar not apple cider
vinegar white wine vinegar yeah um you
run the washer you run the washer
with white wine vinegar and baking soda
and then you run it again and that will
get the moldy smell out i think that's
his problem
so you could even do that without
telling him like you could well she's
gonna go to his mom's house
and fix his washing machine yeah and
then the rest he's not a repair man
like just i mean do you want to have an
uncomfortable conversation or you want
to fix the problem
just i don't think it's mean you're
close smell bro like everyone and you
know
too early in the relationship you talk
about smells no you know what like
everyone in this generation the men need
to grow the [ __ ] up but it's his mom
doing the laundry so you really want to
insult his mother's laundry maybe she
doesn't know
maybe her nose is broken maybe she has
scoped
that's not funny listen
it's too early in the relationship to
talk about smells if you want to
if you just want to why do we have to
put up with so much if this was reversed
the man
wouldn't even think about it two seconds
he'd be like yo [ __ ] your panties smell
like he would say something like he
would
say yo [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of my
house no like honestly
i think that like if the roles were
reversed actually men don't really pick
up on those things go behind his back
and fix his laundry machine no i think
that you need to start off the
relationship being honest like we are
all grown adults we are all responsible
we all have agency over our own lives
like
you want to be walking around and smelly
clothes like you're going to pay the
price like i'm going to tell you your
clothes are smelling
okay you have two you have two paths
forward yeah what kind of man do you
want to be with like a wussy
who like you can't even tell that your
clothes don't smell good
or like a grown man who's like takes it
like a man oh my clothes smell like let
me find the problem like
you know what you could just break up
with him because this is just more
trouble than it's worth
the best advice i've heard all year it's
long distance only been a month like
close to my house
what else is what else is waiting listen
his mom with smelly clothes
honestly you haven't given me one
redeeming quality about can't even sense
that his clothes now
he's very sensitive too like honestly
i could never be with someone sensitive
clearly
all right okay now you have three paths
forward let us know which one you choose
yeah but if you really love him just
clean out that launching machine
no i think i think you're setting a
really bad price it's just like one cup
of white wine vinegar and one cup of
baking soda dash
google it i think you're setting
yourself up for failure or you could be
like or you could be like
i saw this thing on my facebook watch
like if your laundry is like smelling we
should try this
you could make it like a group activity
okay then he'll realize what you're
doing and then he'll feel
stupid i don't think he'll realize all
right third and fine if he didn't
realize his clothes
maybe he's not maybe you should take him
to the doctor his nose is broken
dear beautiful stunning and smart
claudia and jackie love the show so much
listening since day one here's the deal
yesterday my friend's mother threw a
post covered party themed
everything pee everything was pink
purple pastels pineapple
how weird you could dress up pee themed
the party was really p themed because it
was supposed to end in my friend's
sister getting proposed to
so obviously really cute yeah my friend
sister had no clue what was happening
and she thought it would be hilarious to
show up
in a giant penis
i love this girl yeah that's right a
penis costume to her
own proposal obviously no one really
knew what to do because no one wanted to
ruin the surprise proposal
he ended up proposing anyway because it
was the only time his friends and family
would be together until the holidays
needless to say my friend's sister ended
up a little embarrassed being proposed
to has a penis and isn't super happy
with the photos
and her grandmother is throwing a huge
fit over the entire situation
and said he should have just waited
until the holidays when everyone is
together again
that's in like nine months that's insane
what do you think should have happened
and what's the best way to fix this
hard pun intended situation would love
to pass off your advice to my friend and
her sister anyways wild weekend
um love the show thanks okay i think
this is a great story so
beautiful laying into it loves you for
who you are what a funny story for the
kids and by the way like once you start
like doing your
your like engagement photos and your
wedding photos you'll never look at
these proposal photos again and like
you'll just
have the funny story just roll with it
if you're the kind of girl that shows up
in a penis costume like you can handle
this
into it i agree like first of all nobody
even uses the proposal photos everyone
like fake proposes again
later when you have your hair and makeup
done so get just the problem the
solution to this problem is an
engagement photo shoot you wear a white
dress and he wears a suit and he doesn't
send those pictures to grandma yeah and
that's what you put on like your wedding
website but like i think this is a great
story of two young
lovers who are just jokesters and he i
love this story loves you for who you
are
oh and i love that he still did it i
think it's so beautiful this is one of
the best stories i've heard
a happy ending i wasn't expecting a
literal happy ending
lol lean into it um i think it's great
and that was your toasters if you ever
want to write in by the way dear
toasters at gmail.com
write to us with your problems also if
you've ever written to us with your
problems and we answer them on air
and you have an update for us you know
someone got married something
send it to us we like to hear what goes
on in your life to your toasters at
gmail.com
and we're not ending the show because if
you're listening as a podcast coming up
momentarily is our interview with kirby
madison brown
from dynasty great show she was a great
guy she's a huge toaster
she brought her dog if you're watching
on youtube the video is separate but it
is up right now so check that out
and if you want to see the pups being
mad cute check out the youtube yeah the
youtube was kind of precious
yeah um thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning shows we'll see
you tomorrow
goodbye goodbye
you